[Music]
welcome to our 2022 lab roots webinar
series my name is tara niles regional
marketing development manager for life
science electron microscopy from thermo
fisher scientific and your host today
we welcome back our returning attendees
and send a big hello to our new
attendees wherever you are in the world
we are pleased to have two very engaging
speakers lined up for our session today
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them in the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
now please let me introduce today's
speaker
christian waddle is a product marketing
manager for thermo fisher scientific's
cryo-electron microscopy business
he studied molecular biotechnology at
the university of heidelberg and
obtained a phd in neurosciences from
gottingen university
over the last 10 years he has held sales
business development and product
marketing roles in light microscopy
correlative light and electron
microscopy large volume em and cry oem
now christian over to you for your
presentation
welcome everybody to this email
university and thermo fisher scientific
webinar and thank you tara for
introducing me
we're very excited to have dr salma
darman as our guest speaker today as her
work demonstrates the power of
cryo-electron tomography for virus
research
i have chosen this image which you will
learn much more about later as a teaser
because it encapsulates in a nutshell
the beauty of cryovt
it also illustrates something vernatuant
from the mpi in frankfurt wrote in a
very recent review where he said every
cell contains a universe of molecular
landscapes that is best explored by
cryo-et
for those of you who are less familiar
with prior electron tomography i
prepared a very short summary
of the critical steps in that workflow
these six steps in total can be
segmented into three groups and the
first is all about the samples
most commonly these can be proteins
viruses bacteria placed on temp grids or
cells that are cultured on these grids
the next group of steps
can be summarized as sample preparation
on the one hand that's the rapid
freezing to create a vitrified cryo
sample using plunge freezing for example
but it is also
important to understand that the samples
have to be electron transparent for
imaging them in a transmission electron
microscope
algeb cells are too thick to see
anything in the temp except for the very
periphery of the cell so they have to be
thinned down this is being done using a
cryo-focused imb microscope or cryofib
for short illustrated here on the right
depending on the sample under
investigation it might also be necessary
to target specific cells or locations
within a cell using correlative light
and electron microscopy
cryo cryoclaim in this case
which is shown here in the middle
the sample is then transferred to a
cryotm like the cryos shown here
mammography is being performed by
tilting the sample multiple times to
then reconstruct the tomogram from the
recorded projection images
further analysis and segmentation then
ultimately yield
visualizations like the one i showed you
at the beginning of my introduction or
the one being shown
here most important are of course the
results
that can be obtained using cryolith
it's a technique that has grown
significantly both methodologically and
with respect to the scientific output in
fields like cell biology neuroscience
and microbiology
i have picked some visually striking
examples here like the golgi on the left
and er membranes with plenty of
ribosomes at the top
there's an excitatory synapse from
cultured hippocampal neurons on the
right
and phage assembly in a bacterial cell
on the bottom
these are myriad examples
but the scientific questions being
addressed by the researchers behind
these images go much deeper obviously if
you want to learn more about the example
shown here please go to thermofisher.com
cryo minus tomography
where you can find videos about the
workflow itself but also an ebook with
very detailed descriptions about the
data that i show here on the slide
wouldn't i i would now like to draw your
attention once more to the example image
in the lower right corner because it
falls broadly into the category of
research that is the topic for today
namely pathogen host interactions
motivation for using cryovt in these
studies is to observe pathogens as close
as possible to their native state inside
a host cell
depending on the pathogen and sample
preparation this might mean that the
cryvm instruments have to be installed
in a biosafety facility
i think this is a good moment to show
you a one minute video of such a
facility the one we set up ourselves
in bruno in the czech republic because
it gives you an idea of what a cribm
facility looks like and what our
microscopes look like as well instead of
showing illustrations and results only
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
as mentioned in that video our lab is a
bsl2 facility but this year we have also
announced that we can offer a 60 degree
heating
decontamination solution for the crows
it combines heaters
temperature sensors and software with
heaper filters a secondary workstation
so that the microscope can be controlled
from both the inside and the outside of
the biosafety area and remote
diagnostics
this enables the installation in a bsl3
facility and work on pathogens
successful to 60 degree heat
if you're interested in this possibility
please have a look at thermofisher.com
cryo minus em minus biosafety
with this very brief introduction
into the gravity workflow the
instruments involved and where they can
be installed i want to introduce you to
our speaker for today dr salma daman who
will talk about how she uses cryovt to
study enterovirus assembly and release
delma did her bachelor master studies in
the field of cellular structural biology
and then obtained her phd in mopi france
where she studied the interaction of
viruses with the host cell plasma
membrane and developed correlative
atomic force and super-resolution
fluorescence microscopy in order to do
so
currently she is a postdoc in las anders
carlson's lab in the department of
medical biochemistry and biophysics at
umeo university
salma thank you very much for joining us
today we are very excited to have you
here i leave the stage to you
hello everyone thank you christian for
the kind introduction i'm very happy to
be here today and show you the work
we've done using prior electron
tomography to study
enterovirus replication in the cells and
i will start this presentation by giving
a brief introduction on this family of
viruses we work with in the lab
so two things you need to know about
enteroviruses is the fact that there are
non-enveloped and positive single-strand
rna viruses
they have
this um as as you can see on this em
micrograph uh they have this nice
icosahedral capsid shell that is about
30 nanometer they're extremely small
very contagious and responsible for wide
variety of diseases ranging from common
cold to more severe diseases such as
heart inflammation and polymyelitis
these two viruses are actually the two
members of this family that we use as
modal viruses in the lab they are both a
bsl2 level pathogens
and today i will show you mainly the
data i obtained on polio infected cells
now last point is the fact that these
viruses they have the ability to remodel
cellular membrane to replicate
and in the case of poliovirus it
remodels the er and golgi membranes
to form its own organelles so in this
case they form this single tube single
membranes these tubules in the cell as
well as double membrane vesicles these
membranes we know that they are the site
of their viral rna replication
and they are often referred to the name
of replication complexes
now
where virus acidly takes place is not
known eventually the new positive rnas
and proteins they pack together to form
new variants which then leave the cell
by hijacking secretory autophagy inside
these physicals
now how virus does this is not known and
whether this process is connected to
particle formation is not known either
so basically these are the two questions
we try to answer using in-situ
cryo-electron tomography
so to do so we establish an optimized
workflow where we grow human cells on
the em grid we infect them with the
water virus and at defined
post-infection time these cells are
vitrified using vitrobots for example
here
and here i just want to show you an
intermediate step that allowed me to
optimize the conditions like such as uh
virus and cell density in order to be
sure that all the cells that grow on
these em grids are infected and this is
very important especially if you don't
have the possibility to use cryoclamp
prior to cryo-focused inb milling
because you want to make sure that the
cell that you are mailing is infected
so uh
cryofocus imb milling as christian
mentioned it is a sample preparation
method that allows us to make the deep
structures of the cell accessible
through transmission electron microscopy
and now to show you just briefly how it
works this is the frozen cell
seen by uh the electron beam so you have
a top view of this cell now uh down here
is the same cell but seen with the ion
beam where you can see it from the side
this time
so we use the ion beam here to trim away
from above and below a part of the cell
in order to obtain at the end of the
milling process a very thin slice of
this cell you can see this
thin slice now that it's its name is
lamella you can see it here the top view
of this lamella with the electron beam
and this is the lamella thickness
distribution i obtained in this study
and typically you want to have very thin
lamellas especially if you
are interested to use a subtomogram
averaging and this this lamellas are the
ones that give you the best tomogram
with the highest resolution
however in the beginning of a project
it's also useful to have thicker
lamellas this lamellas will give you
more cellular context and by this i mean
that you will have more information on
how the virus or the pathogen that you
are working with is changing the
anterior of the cell
now of course the final step is to uh
transfer the lamellas to the cryos and
here you can see an image of them under
the tm
so you see this lamella is
nicely transparent to the electrons and
already at low magnification we can
observe cellular structures
so these are the regions where i
acquired tilt series to generate at the
end a 3d volume of this
the infected cytoplasm
so this is what i'm going to show you
now i will jump to the result parts in
this slide where i want to show you two
representative tomograms of affected
cells at the early time point and
electrolyte state of infection
so here is uh to show you that the
replication complex is formed by by the
polio virus
at early time point what we see mainly
is single membranes you can see vesicles
as well as tubules
and close to this membrane you can
recognize some virus particles here this
dark particles
and now at the late stage of affection
we start to see that there are double
membrane vesicles as well with the
single membranes and we know that these
structures here are hallmark of
autophagy activation
now i will let you appreciate the
evolution of affection throughout the
time
where here you have a comp computational
slices going back and forth within the
3d volume
so this is the kind of resolution we can
get with cryo electron tomography and i
will show you now in the next slides uh
the different uh features new findings
that we could report using this method
so here is a snapshot of the tomogram i
showed you in the previous slide and
this is a 3d segmentation of this area
where the different structures that you
can
visualize here are color coded
um now what we could observe in all the
tomograms of the infected cell is two
different assembly capsid states
we can see empty particles basically
they do not they do not contain the
viral rna and we can see here rna loaded
variants which are these dark particles
here and strikingly this capsid were
tethered to the membrane at their
vicinity so you can see that it was the
case for the single but also to the
autophagy membranes
and when we did the statistic very
interesting we realized that this
tethering it happens mainly on the
cytoplasmic phase of the membranes
indeed if you see this variant which get
got engulfed inside this double membrane
vesicle it lost its tether
and this is a very important observation
which led us to question whether this
tethering
is helping the rna encapsidation because
we know that this uh
the viral rna replicates on these
membranes
so to verify this hypothesis we used an
antiviral drug high donatory that has
been shown to inhibit rna on capsidation
even though you have poliocapsis
particles forming in the cell
so we infected the cell we treated them
with the drug and what we see in this
case very striking is an abundance of
empty particles in this in the cytoplasm
here
and the increase of empty particle
formation correlated with the loss of
the tether upon this treatment compared
to untreated cell here
so this should stress uh strongly that
we have a tether that forms and help rna
incorporation in the capsid
and so the formation of a new infectious
particle
and now i guess you wonder
where actually the viral capsids
assemble in the cytoplasm and as i
mentioned before it is one of the major
open question in the field so we looked
carefully into the tomograms of the
cells and we found that there are capsid
assembly intermediates and docked on the
single membranes as you can see in this
3d segmentation
and these intermediates were also found
on autophagy membranes and very rarely
alone in the cytoplasm
and here is to show you that they have
different conformation you can see it in
this different snapshots also different
level of completion
however we measured their closure degree
and we found that most of them
correspond to health capsids
so
here now i want to sum up this first
part of the results
what we could report using in
citrocryoity is that viral capsid
assembly takes place on the replication
complexes with the prominent half capsid
intermediate
and
there is eventually a tether that helps
rna encapsulation during the assembly
process
in the second part of the resource i
want to show you how we unravel the
roles of autophagy in virus replication
and uh what we did is we tried to find
a host autophagy factors that support a
virus assembly in this case we used a
drug that inhibits vps34 this is a lipid
kinase very important in autophagy
activation as uh it's
it helps the maturation and formation of
autophagy membranes so we um inhibited
this protein and what we see in this
case very surprising the virus is still
able to activate autophagy you can see
it that
the the the the membranes phagophores
and also double membrane physicals are
forming in the cell however very
striking here there are no more
assembled variants in the cytoplasm what
we mainly observe are capsid
intermediates here again docked on the
membranes so you can see
here clearly on the 5go4 a single
membrane tubule or a double membrane
physical here
and indeed we calculated the number of
complete particles whether it's empty or
rna-loaded variants together with the
capsid intermediate and we see that upon
this treatment compared to untreated
cell we have a drastic decrease of
complete particles density however the
density of capsid intermediates remain
the same
so this means that upon the inhibition
of eps 34 we have a virus assembly that
goes to a point in forming this
intermediate but it does not go further
so we stole the virus assembly on the
membrane
and i like it very much of this snapshot
where we could uh
we
kind of caught a stage where
this intermediate is different from this
one the health capsid and close to the
tethered particle i showed you earlier
so we like to think that this is kind of
the evolution of assembly from the
intermediate to a complete particle
tethered to the membranes
next we did a very surprising uh
discovery we found that the normal way
of cells to activate autophagy limits
virus replication and we did that by
using an inhibitor of the ulc complex
it's a very
it's a combination of two protein
kinases
which are the initiator of canonical
autophagy
in this case we see that the virus goes
completely crazy it forms this large
arrays in the cytoplasm typically in one
array we have more than 600 particles
stuck on top of each other in this
really beautiful crystal-like
arrangement
and this was true for half of the cell
treated with this drug compared to
untreated cells
now it correlated interestingly with the
increase
of uh the release of infectious
particles from the cell especially at
this later time point when you where you
can see that there is one order of
magnitude of increase of a particle
release from the cells
and this shows that unlike ps34 that has
a pro-viral rule in poliovirus infection
the old complex has an antiviral role
and puts a break in virus replication
puts a break on virus replication
and now i just want to finish this talk
by showing you
how the autophagy membranes select and
solve their contents and here is an
example of phago force as well as double
membrane physicals engulfing mature
variants as you can see here as well in
this
3d segmentations
and we could see sometimes empty capsid
as well in the double membrane physicals
however when we did this statistic we
realized that even though we have
anticapsids forming in the cytoplasm
only subset of them ends up in the
autophage membranes
and this shows that we have a strong
selectivity towards rna-loaded variants
where anti-capsids are completely
excluded from the autophagy membranes
and we like to think that this is a way
of the virus to
leave the cell inside this physicals
by hijacking secretory autophagy
and now just uh to show you how powerful
is is this method especially if you're
interested in autophagy you can
basically make a catalog of autophagy
membranes depending on what they contain
how the structures segregate in
different classes or co-segregate in one
class and for instance here we could
often observe these dense granules they
have this amorphous structures
different from the viral particles
however they were often co-packed
together in the same autophagy membranes
and here i want you i want to
want you to pay attention on this uh
very distinct class of autophagy
membrane that contain this
filament bundles as you can see here in
this autophagosome
and these filaments were rarely
pegged together with the viral particles
or the dense granules
with its
subtomogram averaging to obtain an
initial structure of these filaments and
we can see here that they have this very
nice helical twist they're about 10
nanometer
now the resolution that we got so far
does not allow me today to tell you
exactly what they are however what we've
done is to uh search in the emdb
host filament structures
that could correspond to the filament we
observe in this study so we compare them
to different filaments here which makes
sense with the virus
virus infection context
and we uh see that actually the
decorated actin here pinkillin actin uh
structure
co fits the structure of the filaments
we observe um engulfed in autophagy
membranes
so we are investigating more into this
and i hope next time i will be able to
tell you exactly what they are
so with this i would like to sum up and
show you that using in-situ
cryo-electron tomography we could
report that enterovirus accidentally
happens on the replication membranes and
that the vps 34 lipid kinase is
important in this process
we see that there is a tethering of the
newly sensitized capsids on the
membranes and this helps rna
loading and we see as well that the
autophagy membranes select
material variants over empty capsids and
that there are
filament bundles engulfed by the
autophagy membranes in the infected cell
and finally the canonical autophagy is
important to limit virus replication and
in case of inhibition we see that
the
virus forms arrays and increases
the virus particle
release
and with this i would like to thank all
the members of the lab and especially my
supervisor lars anders carson our
collaborators uh nihal el temponi and
eileen cardiel at nih for the virus
release uh essays distinguished for his
help in subtomogram averaging and
michael azaru at monash university for
gifting us the knockout cells
the funding as well as the ucm it's the
core facility where all these images
were obtained
and with this i would like to thank you
all with you
for your intention sorry and i'm very
happy to take your question if you have
any
thank you
wonderful thank you very much selma
these were really impactful results it
was fascinating to visualize how
inhibition stalls viral assembly and
some some really uh interesting tidbits
that we all picked up on there thank you
all right so now we will start the uh
interactive part of our webinar and we
will turn it over to questions and
answers
we've got a couple of questions already
rolling in here thank you and just a
reminder if you do have any questions
then please do enter them into the q a
and hit send and we'll be happy to
answer as many questions as we can
accommodate today
okay so the first question is for you
selma
what made you choose cryo et as a
technique or in other words what what
are the advantages of doing institute
tomography for you
thank you tara yeah um
so
of course with the resolution that you
can get with cryo-electron tomography uh
before there were more images with some
reason uh embedded sections from
infected cells which gave a lot of good
information how this replication
complexes look like in the infected cell
but the virus we are interested in is
about 30 nanometers it's quite small so
if we want to
catch its assembly we need to have a
method that can reach uh that can reach
a resolution that will allow us to
observe the different stages of the smd
for instance or macro liquidator
structures
perfect thank you
all right and
another related
question is how much work was it to
establish this workflow for your
research and is it routine for you now
yeah i'm happy to say that it's a
routine now in the lab definitely
but uh when i started this project
so
it's um it depends because me i started
from the scratch so i didn't work with
em before so i had to learn how to
handle em grips which was very difficult
in the beginning so
this is uh really important if you if
you have nice grease flat grip cells
grow nicely on the grids the feed
milling punch freezing team meeting goes
perfectly
i would say
if someone is already
already have an experience with the ems
can go faster but otherwise it took me
almost one
almost two years one year and a half
because once you get used to with the
uh all the different microscope get to
learn how to work with then um
it's much easier to play with your
samples and try different things
yeah right
yeah for sure the more that you spend
time working on it the more uh easily uh
it becomes routine
yeah yeah you need to spend a lot of
time with the sample preparation of
course the cell density on the em grid
is very important to get a very thin
eyes and
yeah
and make sure that all the cells are
infected as well
yes yeah a lot of crucial steps in the
process that make or breakers
good great thank you and uh let's uh
let's have a question for christian now
um christian from a methodological
perspective
where do you expect to see significant
improvements in the cryoet workflow
well one one point for sure resolution
always i think what we're seeing
nowadays is that cryot follows a little
bit the path of single particle analysis
where we also saw significant
improvements over time
so that's one resolution throughput is
the other so there's still plenty that
can be done
on the instrument level that would
produce more
data in shorter amounts of time
and then of course much like single part
analysis i think on the
computational level analysis
um
automation there improvements also to
resolution on that level i think there's
still a lot of room
to go beyond so then selma can see which
filaments uh these are actually
that you found there
thank you yeah technology is always uh
is always changing to meet the the
latest in demand
thank you
and uh selma another one for you um
for your research do you have ideas
already on what you want to study next
uh do you have other pathogens that
you'd want to work on
uh yes i mean at the moment uh in the
lab we are
trying to
get more
information on how another virus
replicates in the cell which is
also part of the enterovirus family it's
a cocci virus b3 and it infects the
cardiomyocytes
so we are working on that at the moment
yes
excellent thank you yeah
cool
that'll be it'll be nice to stay in
touch and to see what the future holds
together
listen to yep
excellent thank you
and maybe this one is for either of you
um
let's see the uh the one thing i did not
see in the video was the cryo
preparative process on done in the bsl2
environment
specifically freezing via plunge freezer
or high pressure freezer
how are the aerosols handled
maybe i can start and then someone can
correct me or or add to how how they are
doing it in
[Music]
an email um
generally speaking of course by safety
regulations are a local
thing so
you know whatever i'm going to say now
is very much based on what i've seen it
doesn't mean that it's globally true or
universally true
for bsl-2 environments uh from from what
i've saw seen
is that um sample preparation including
plunge freezing is usually uh
limited to to rooms that are physically
separate from the microscope rooms
so a clear separation across the hallway
for example rooms that are dedicated to
just that nothing else
and just to keep areas of of higher
concentration of higher passages and
hypothetical higher
concentration of pathogens separate from
the microscope where generally on the
temp grid
concentrations are much much lower
but no no further limitations i've also
seen at least in one case like an
aquarium inside
the lab in a sense so a physical
separate area for sample preparation
there was essentially a glass box
installed
within
the microscopy lab that you could walk
into
so in a sense again physical separation
aerosol specifically of course is a huge
topic for psl3
and there from um everything that i've
seen and heard is that usually plunge
freezing devices are installed in
biosafety cabinets so it's directly
inside
so it's an again physically separated of
course but then additionally placed in
the biosafety cabinet but that's from
what i can tell
limited to pso3 this requirement
for high pressure freezing i have to
admit um
i don't haven't seen a whole lot of them
i would assume that for bsl 2 is the
same as a plunge freezer i have never
seen a high pressure freezer
in a vso3 lab and i doubt that you could
install it inside a biosafety cabin so
there i have to admit i don't i just
don't know the answer
thank you selma you can add to how
you're doing it which i think is a bsl2
facility in your case
yes it is um so i mean it's what you
said is
this is what we are doing also we have a
physical separation between the
microscope and the planche freezing room
the cryo room
also we um so everybody is aware that
it's the bsl2 sample preparation room so
you have to wear gloves whatever you do
in this room
and then you need to make sure that you
follow the instruction for the pathogen
you're working with so um
depends if you can
decontaminate with eta no if you need
something more
stronger to kill them
so you would need to use that then we
use a small plastic pads
on the vehicle to protect the pads the
sponges so that nobody
like after the bloating nothing goes
through the filter paper and goes to the
pad so that we use that um
yes and then we make sure that we
decontaminate all the surfaces the
tweezers
so that's the routine
excellent
thank you that that gives some insight
into
a new environment that really has a
tremendous amount of potential for the
future for hopefully many
more scientists to
go down this path
okay
next question beautiful talk and
beautiful work
any hypothesis on the mechanism by which
vps34 interferes with fires assembly
thank you um
so
we we did uh many measurements uh under
this treatment and we also checked if
the viral rna replication is ongoing um
so we see that there is a decrease by
compared to untreated cells but
it's not as significant uh compared to
the decrease of virus particle assembly
um
so
there is something going on with virus
assembly and we don't know yet exactly
uh definitely we have less membrane so
let's say that most of the cells did not
make
as much as membranes uh replication
complexes as compared to treated and
treated cells
so it's only in the cells where they
still manage to uh activate autophagy
and have membranes that we could see
these intermediates
so it could be that
the
it's also involved in the formation of
the replication complexes and so
the site of the virus assembly is not
um
is available is not available under this
treatment as much as
in entries itself so there are many
hypotheses but uh it's difficult to say
perfect thank you
all right lots of
lots of great questions here uh and
great comments too uh great talk
does your data show where the ds rna
intermediate is
so and no um it's it's difficult to say
if
so we have some uh
structures uh inside the membranes and
also the similar densities outside in
the cytoplasm so it's difficult to say
if this is the
um
double stranded rna
um the the the cell the cytoplasm is so
crowded that it's really difficult to
say the pinpoint and say that this is
the
the double strand rna so
after the the paper with the seed
milling on the
corona affected cells where we see this
poor complex on the double membrane
vesicles through the that allows
potentially the viral rna to go from the
replication complex to the cytoplasm i
don't see such a pore on the replication
complexes of
polio virus
so
the only protein that can make pores on
the membranes is the viral porin and
it's a 20 kilo dalton so it's really
small if there is
there are pores in the membranes i
wouldn't be able to see them anyway
so yeah the answer to the question just
short and no i cannot say if we can see
it's probably there but i can't say
where it is
perfect thank you
all right um this is a good question
hi and thanks for your nice presentation
can you tell me how many tomograms did
you select for subtomogram averaging
so yeah we had to do a very stringent uh
selection um so we took the best
tomograms like the best ones also in
terms of alignment because we use
um patch tracking we have no fiduciary
on lamella so you you end up with a few
thomograms at the end so i had 16
tomograms uh
16 tomograms for the subtomogram
averaging then we used the fiber tracing
model on amira
so i first traced the filaments and then
we took this coordinate to dynamo for
uh making selfie volumes and
the operating yeah so 16
yes
great a great way of incorporating
really the entire workflow and
reconstruction
with
subtomogram averaging fantastic
okay a couple more questions here
um congratulations on such beautiful
work i would like to ask you whether you
are able to test the output of viable
infectious viruses arising from the
conditions you tested
[Music]
so
i'm not sure i understood the question
um
i think the question maybe is um
are you able to test the output
of infectious viruses arising from the
condition of yeah i understand that the
uh the confusion because of course these
are
um
if the viruses tend to
um
if they can be still infectious
uh they are um
[Music]
if this is the question uh
so this uh our virus is the ones that
are formed inside the cell
are viruses that are released um at some
point and they are infectious yes
thank you
okay um let's see uh maybe christian if
you'd like to uh to jump in um
this is another question or either one
of you can answer
can mitochondria be visualized via this
method
yes
would be my answer
yeah you can see them definitely
great
yeah beautifully in fact
great all right um
so let's see um
let's see another question is can you
see some physical properties of the
vesicles
comparing to other techniques
like afm
um
it would be difficult because here what
we have is a snapshot so we
um
the only thing that we can measure is
the volume the
of the double mumble and physical the
size
and
yeah
it's
not possible to have
information on how they are
more physical information than this yeah
so
yeah
i don't know if the person is thinking
about a specific
uh property but
i would say
that's what you can get the volume and
still
you need to keep in mind that we are
feed milling so
uh it happens often that we don't have
the
whole 3d volume of the physical
so um
the more you make tomograms of color
more lamellas you will have an idea what
they uh the similar what i've done here
that the different classes of autophagy
membranes with different content it's
because i have several tomograms on the
same condition and i can make statistics
but
otherwise
it's snapshots so no dynamic no physical
properties more than that
so thank you
okay then we're we're getting down to
the last couple of questions so i'll
just remind our attendees if you'd like
to
ask any final questions please do so
um
i've got another request for a comment
here
thanks for the wonderful presentation
on the comment is about the particles
assembly assembled in arrays the
conclusion was that secretion of the
particles increased
but didn't the transfer into the
membrane vesicles get interrupted
and the particles need to be inside for
secretion is is this correct
yeah thank you for the question i i
didn't show it in the in this
presentation but so you you can see we
can see we report also that the
secretion of viruses in um
and the
vesicles is also increased in this case
with this treatment
um now
the assay virus release assay was done
on the
supernatant so we don't know exactly
if
uh the um the increase of infectivity is
due to these arrays
or the physicals together so it's
difficult to um separate between the two
whether these arrays are infectious
today lies the cell and they explode and
then they can propagate it's uh
it's
it's an open question but i think we are
we can do something we can
we measure the membrane integrity and
see if
there is
an increase of cell permeability due to
these arrays because it resembles to the
lytic version of some viruses for
instance adenoviruses they form this
kind of arrays
i hope i answered this question
thank you
um and this is uh this is a great
question for for either of you again
thank you for the nice talk
uh these lamellae are very fragile and
you mentioned you have the best data
from the very thin ones
can you estimate your success rate of
lamella cutting and do you have a trick
to make them very thin
should i answer christian or do you
okay
i think i know thomas hey
uh um but uh yes so it's um
it's a good question because uh
yeah you need to
always expect to lose at least half of
the lamellas on the way
um uh
let's say
um
i'm losing less lamellas now but it's
true that you take a risk whether it's
on the feed milling when you are at the
last step of polishing where you try to
have it in
a very thin lamella and you can see that
you are really risking to just cut in
the middle and lose completely the
lamella or during the transfer
i would say yeah
half it's really a lot but yeah
something like that um
i usually what i do is i have two
sessions on
science let's say in one session i i put
two three grids and i try to make four
cells per grids and so i end up with 12
lamellas
and on cryos i can find
eight goods
sometimes with six so it's something
like roughly like this yeah
and you need to also think about this
just not losing the it can crack and
then it's not stable enough to do
a tilt theory and also you can have a
contamination opportunity exactly where
you want to take it to series
so
yeah
great thank you your expertise really
shines throughout thank you for sharing
with us
pleasure
all right great
so um this brings us to the conclusion
of our q a and uh before we go i'd like
to share a little bit more information
with you um so
christian mentioned the biosafety level
labs and
we showed a short video earlier in
today's presentation i'd like to share
the links with you so that you can
explore a little bit more detail please
visit our website um as you see here
cryo-em-biosafety
to learn a little bit more of the
specifics on how you can incorporate
this into your facility as well
and also um i'd like to bring your
attention to upcoming events so we have
had a successful day today and we look
forward to future successful sessions
with lab roots and uh you can find all
of the upcoming events uh
on in the agenda
as well as any on-demand past events
you're able to access
[Music]
okay
and so
as we wrap up today we'd like to send a
very big thank you uh to the audience
for joining us today and really for the
amazing and interesting questions that
it's very clear uh somewhat that your
presentation was so well received and
really very impactful based on the great
questions that you have received
if there are any more questions that
come in that we did not have time for
today we will reach out to you with the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast and others are found in the
series uh with a link that was provided
and we encourage you to share this
session with your colleagues who may
have missed today's event certainly if
there are other
sessions that you'd like to see
please visit the on demand section of
the events
you can also register for upcoming
events uh the next one that you'll find
on the link is on april 27th with
researchers at mrc lmv and their
classification of towelpathies using
cryoem
and you can find more about biosafety
via the link provided as well as
additional tools on the thermo-fisher
website in the cryo-em learning center
i'd like to
give a very big thank you to our
speakers selma and christian and all of
our organizers and especially to
everybody who joined us today
we will see you next time thank you and
goodbye
you